you just think that anyone can come to
the U.S like absolutely
go to New York go to the Statue of
Liberty to say
I don't think it says that but dude this
is great because okay I just happen to
pick up um three guys from Honduras
while they were at Home Depot they're
they're from Honduras and they have
nowhere to go so this just works out
perfect look
um Hector takes medication twice a day
and and
right now they got to use the bathroom
all three of them
is it cool if they stay here no
let's go guys let's go sorry man
hypocrite
look I don't know if that was set up or
not but Hector takes medication that
should be the title of today's show
Hector takes medication the three of
them have to poop come on man I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report it is
June 6 2022 we are live streaming on
Rumble YouTube and locals subscribe
wherever you are watching if you have
not already and if you want to join us
for the post game show at
reubenreport.locals.com I'm in a
particularly good mood this morning and
I sense we have a fine show for you the
theme today is if you did not see it
yesterday well I know you didn't see it
live because you're always watching the
Reuben report at 11 A.M Eastern but you
might have seen some clips of South
Carolina Senator and now presidential
candidate Tim Scott go on The View now
when the view was created it was to
offer many different view points Barbara
Walters is long gone off this Mortal
coil and the show has devolved into
basically one View and if you don't bow
to that view they will call you a racist
and a homophobic transform and
everything else so anyway Tim Scott went
on got into it with sunny got into it
the other host it's just crazy we got a
couple clips of that but I wanted to
start with that to really set us up
not only on the race thing which a
certain set of people refused to let go
of but of course the sexuality and
gender thing and now how it's related to
children with which again a certain set
of people and there's a lot of overlap
if I was uh Kamala Harris I would say
there's a Venn diagram showing the
overlap of these race obsessed and
sexuality obsessed people but there is a
glimmer a teeny tiny glimmer of hope in
the Democrat Party just a flicker little
little Ember of something for the
Democrats and it's RFK Jr obviously
we're going to get him on the show soon
we're just working on the date on that
but he went on Jordan Peterson's podcast
and Jordan you guys know my feelings
about Jordan and obviously really I
think our you know Prime public
intellectual really in the entire world
but he's also become an excellent
interviewer and I'm going to show you a
little clip of that and just remember as
we set up today's show even though I'm
going to be exposing these people and
making fun of these people and mocking
these people I think it's very important
that we all remember that Democrats are
Americans too okay
no matter how badly they don't want to
be and we have to do our best to help
them all of that in mind we'll get to it
in just a moment but first let me talk
to you guys about ramp uh do you feel
like your financing software isn't
cutting it I want the latest and
greatest in financial software to
simplify spending help you save time and
keep you from getting trapped in busy
work check out ramp ramp is the
corporate card and expense management
software designed to help you save time
and put money back in your pocket ramp
gives Finance teams unprecedented
control and insight into company spend
with ramp you're able to issue cards to
every employee with limits and
restrictions and automate expense
reporting so you can stop wasting time
at the end of every month ramp's
accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to that way when Connor orders extra
guacamole I am alerted about it you'll
never have to chase down a receipt again
and your employees will no longer spend
hours submitting expense reports the
time you'll save each month on employee
expenses will close lose your books
eight times faster ramp saves you money
businesses that use ramp save an average
of 3.5 percent of the first year and now
get 250 when you join ramp just go to
ramp.com Ruben that's ramp.com Reuben
and now back to me all right South
Carolina Senator presidential candidate
and decent human being I have had him on
the show before this is a very I think
you would say moderate Republican good
dude happens to be black I would say
happens to be black he's a senator from
the south okay I've given you a little
bio there 57 years old running for
president of the United States he went
on The View and God bless him for doing
it and here is Tim Scott or sunny host
you have indicated that you don't
believe in systemic racism what is your
definition of systemic racism let me
answer the question that you've answered
or does it even exist in your mind let
me answer the question this way one of
the things I think about and one of the
reasons why I'm on the show is because
of the comments that were made frankly
on this show that the only way for a
young African-American kid to be
successful in this country is to be the
exception and not the rule that is a
dangerous offensive disgusting message
to send to our young people today that
the only way to succeed is by being the
exception I will tell you that if my
life is the exception I can't imagine it
is but it's not actually here's here's
114 years yeah so so the fact of the
matter is we've had an African-American
president African-American vice
president we've had two
African-Americans to be secretaries of
the state in my home City the police
chief is an African-American who's now
running for mayor the head of the
highway patrol for South Carolina is the
African-American
in 1975 there was about 15 employment in
the African-American Community for the
first time in the history of the country
it's under five percent forty percent
homelessness and fifty percent of the
folks in our community 13 of the
population ask the question I've watched
you on the show that you like people to
be deferential and respectful so I'm
going to do the same thing so here's
what I'm going to suggest I'm going to
suggest the fact of the matter is that
progress in America is palpable it could
be measured in Generations I look back
at the fact that my grandfather born in
1921 in Sally South Carolina when he was
on a on a sidewalk a white person was
coming he had to step off and not make
eye contact that man believed then with
some doubt now and the goodness of
America because he believed that having
faith in God faith in himself and faith
in what the future could hold for his
kids would unleash opportunities in ways
that you you cannot imagine
all right I want to put aside the the
numbers and specifics for a second I'll
talk a little bit about that but isn't
there something so refreshing about not
just hearing truth I always talk about
that but something aspirational like Tim
Scott he is saying my life
me guys sitting next to you sonny host
and as you look at me like this with
that body language I mean she is such a
piece of work that I am not the
exception right and then I can list out
all of these other people and she's like
well those are acceptance exceptions too
how many people have to succeed for it
not to be the exception right and then
when she starts talking about
unemployment and these things and other
things it's like well we can talk about
behaviors we can talk about government
programs that have destroyed the family
and all of those things but if he was to
bring up any of those things obviously
it was not going to go well and it
devolved we'll get to that in just a
minute uh but you know even this idea
that you know America's had a black
president and we have plenty of black
senators in congressmen and all that and
a black VP and everything else you know
America is a fairly Young country we're
only 250 some odd years old there are
nations in Europe westernized nations in
Europe that have existed for hundreds
and thousands of years in essence that
have never had black Prime Ministers
presidents etc etc that tells you you it
doesn't say something specific oh
because that's just one job but it tells
you something about the culture of the
people we have long let this stuff go
there is no quarter of American society
in any way that has anything to do with
anything roughly mainstream that where
racism is acceptable and this idea of
systemic racism and this is where
unfortunately because we all have
different definitions for things it can
get quite confusing the idea of systemic
racism that racism is built into the
system if you were asking me to Define
that I would go by the definition that
Tim Scott has and and I would say most
most thoughtful people have which is
that if you're saying something systemic
that it means it has to be built into
the system like oh black people can't
drink out of these water fountains we
are going to stop you from going on this
street you are not going to get this
loan there's going to be laws that you
can't do this that or the other thing
none of those things exist none of those
things exist so it is not in the system
are there individuals who happen to be
racist of course there are and there's
always going to be them and the best you
can do as I always say is show them that
racism and collectivism is not the way
forward unfortunately it's the lefties
that love collectivism right like she
Sunny Hosten ironically loves the thing
that is feeding racism but anyway it
continued and then they had to actually
had to cut to commercial because it was
going so Haywire
every kid today can look just change the
stations and see how much progress has
been made in this country ABC NBC CBS
ESPN CNN
Fox News all have African-American and
Hispanic hosts so what I'm suggesting is
that the yesterday's exception is
today's Rule and for us has met its
promise no of course the the concept of
America is that we are going to become a
more perfect union but in fact the
challenges that we face
50 years ago and 60 years ago should not
be the same challenges that we face
today and here's a way that you you
measured that when my mother was born
about 10 of African-Americans got a high
school degree diploma today is over 90
percent when you look at the income when
you look at the income success that we
found HBCU staff well listen hbcus app
is a good one because one of the reasons
why I took the funding for hbcus to the
highest level in the history of the
country and then I helped make it
permanent is because I believe that
education is the closest thing to Magic
in America so I'm about making sure that
our kids have as many opportunities to
succeed as possible it's one of the
reasons why the opportunity because I
have to go to bed
people can see the success that I've had
oh we'll be right back
[Applause]
whoa whoa whoa now this is the view
you're not going to be making too much
sense on this program we got to cut the
commercial you can be guaranteed look I
get the television shows have certain
rules there's clocks they have to hit
and everything else if they were
crushing him and annihilating him there
is no chance in high hell I'd bet the
farm that they would have been cutting
to commercial right there he's on such a
beautiful Soliloquy of Truth with an
aspirational message and again sunny
hoston
like is there anyone who is more
unlikable on television and I watch
clips of Joy Reid so I know what
unlikable people are but that face she
has that dismissiveness it is just so
absolutely incredible so what what is
the thesis really of today's show well I
want to remind you of a quote that we've
read a few times over the years uh by
economists and and really the guy out of
all the interviews I've ever done that I
that I probably they can put it on my on
my gravestone that I did this one uh
this is of course Thomas Soul uh racism
is not dead but it is on life support
kept Alive by politicians race Hustlers
and people who get a sense of
superiority by denouncing others as
racist and I think that's exactly what
we are seeing really all over Society
these days with the false accusations of
racism but really what comes out of
particularly that show and Sunny Hosten
and these types of people all day long
that no matter what black people
accomplish whether you're president of
the United States or you're a senator or
you're an astronaut or you're a freaking
basketball player or whatever it might
be you're always the exception right
that's never the rule because we want to
keep you thinking you're oppressed
because if we can keep you thinking
you're oppressed we can control you we
literally can control you and then by
the way you'll never look at our
policies right you'll never look at
those big government policies that give
handouts to people that keep them
trapped in poverty and everything else
right that's the last thing the
Democrats want you to do it's why the
it's why on The View they never show you
the crime that's in Chicago every
weekend right it's sunny hostage she's
so concerned about black people I think
at least 50 black people were shot in
Chicago this weekend it's why the NCAA
and NAACP not the NCAA why they don't
issue a travel warning for Chicago where
black people are being shot by black
people but they will issue it for
Florida where literally nothing bad is
happening to black people and there's
more black small business ownership than
any other state in the Union but we will
continue to break this down in just a
moment let me talk to you about home
title lock guys you know the deed to our
homes is the only document that proves
that you own it the problem is the Deeds
to all our homes are online right now a
criminal can find Forge your signature
and refile as the new owner of your home
then they'll take out loans using your
home's equity and leave you in debt you
won't know this until the collection
notices show up as loans you never took
out homeowners insurance doesn't cover
you at neither the common identity theft
programs home title lock is your peace
of mind that the deed to your home is
protected go to hometidalock.com Dave
and use promo code Dave enter your
address for a no obligation home title
scan to see if you're already a victim
that's a hundred dollar a hundred dollar
value absolutely free be sure to use is
my promo code Dave for your free title
scan at home titlelock.com Dave promo
code Dave and now back to me let's pull
up that tweet one more time because it
is the uh the framing of the show today
racism is not dead but it is on life
support kept Alive by politicians race
Hustlers and people who get a sense of
superiority by denouncing others as
racists so politicians this might be
like Joe Biden for example constantly
saying that every Republican is ultra
Maga racist white supremacist
etc etc the race Hustlers like a sunny
Hosten like a Joy Reed we can go through
this endlessly and now we will give you
something going on in the news right now
the New York Times itself is a race
hustling organization so listen to the
way they frame this story this is from
The New York Times
about 10 of offers to New York City's
most elite public high schools went to
Black and Latino students this year
education officials announced on
Thursday in a school system where they
make up more than two-thirds of the
overall student population of the
overall of the student population
overall okay so now if you read that and
this is what lefties do with most things
the average person reads that and they
go my God two-thirds of the students are
somehow black or brown but only 10 got
in that must be racism this is what uh
Sunny Hosten and many other people would
call systemic racism there must be some
thing within the system some bug in the
system that is stopping black people
from getting into these high schools and
it must be that the principals are
racist there's a racist policy they're
looking at people's skin color and
they're saying we don't want black
people here well Wesley Yang who's
actually a great journalist he uh looked
at that headline and did some digging uh
we confirmed this everybody took the
exact same test that was the sole
Criterion for admissions 64 were Asian
and this gets to the Crux of it
when you say you are for Equity meaning
we want everyone to end up in the same
place which is a communist idea it
sounds good for a moment oh it would be
nice everybody will end up in the exact
same place but then to eliminate what
you perceive as racism in this case
against black people you must be racist
against other people and usually these
days it's not white people it's actually
Asian people so Asian people and we can
discuss all the reasons why right it's
somewhat controversial but Asian people
who by and large focus on family and
education tiger mom right all of that
stuff they generally speaking work very
hard it's a cultural thing okay they are
scoring very high on these tests which
as Wesley pointed out was the sole
Criterion to get into these Elite high
schools so if you are for Equity as
Sunny Hostin is if she looks at this and
says this is racist what she is saying
is we should take certain students based
on skin color who score worse in these
things for whatever reason we should put
them in these schools and then in the
first version of that would be like
people would be like oh that's really
great we're helping people who need help
but of course the second version of it
the next the second order of things is
oh I'm going to have to punish a young
Asian kid who worked very hard to do
that now as you guys know this is
exactly what they're doing at Harvard
right now they are still doing it at
Harvard Harvard felt they had too many
Asians I don't even know what that means
they had too many Asians this is crazy
this is what they used to do with Jews
decades ago
we have too many Jews we have too many
Asians we don't like that they're
scoring well uh they seem to do the work
that we ask them to do and they go off
and they succeed in life but we're not
really interested in that we have this
new woke ideology here and then
ultimately of course as you guys know
what you do is if you say to a certain
kid you're going to get into a elite
high school with lesser grades you're
going to get into an elite college with
lesser grades you're going to get into
an elite med school or grad school with
the job that you want with lesser
qualifications eventually our planes
will fall out of the sky and our heart
doctors will not know how to perform
surgery
etc etc and then you will have actual
racists because there will be people who
will not want black Pilots or heart
doctors because they're going to want to
know what the pedigree was to get them
that far that is where this is all going
but let's continue uh on this it's not
just the New York Times the way they
frame it the New York Times wants their
base they want the readers of the New
York Times to think that the system is
racist so Sunny Hosten can then say it
to Tim Scott but check this out uh this
is from outkick Jamel Hill and Jamel
hill was a ESPN sports person she got
eventually fired by ESPN and a big thing
uh she moved on was having a podcast
over at Spotify Jamel Hill is out at
Spotify after daring the company to pay
her or another black host a hundred
million dollars to match Joe Rogan
Spotify said no there's a quick update
on this story that adds a little color
here uh Jamel Hill says what has been
reported about her isn't true she says
her podcast was not canceled but didn't
deny the cited Bloomberg report that she
is leaving Spotify in fact she states
she is leaving due to investment and
growth differences which Bloomberg
reported and is cited below was due to
Spotify needing to rein in costs and
deliver profits she also said she never
directly asked Spotify for 100 million
that is correct but as also reported
below she publicly challenged Spotify to
hand a hundred million to someone who is
Black somebody as in one person meaning
herself or another black podcaster as
reported it's unclear what hill sought
to accomplish with her tweet perhaps all
she cleared up is that she would be out
of the company but has not left you
really need to understand the craziness
of of this type of thing so Jamil Hill
who as I said she was at ESPN she went
really woke we know what's happened to
ESPN parent company Disney their ratings
are in the tank they've turned so many
people off of sports altogether you guys
know I don't I love basketball I love
basketball more than anything basically
except my kids and my husband and I
don't watch basketball anymore I have no
idea what's going on in the NBA Finals I
just don't care anymore I watch old
games because ESPN went so woke and it
just like you don't turn on a basketball
game and you're racist and you're a
homophobic okay so then she moves to
Spotify but this claim this ridiculous
claim that that Spotify to prove that
they are not racist should give a host
whether it is her or anyone else
that they should give a host 100 million
dollars a black host is crazy do you
know why they gave Joe Rogan 100 million
dollars Joe Rogan has by far it's not
even close as successful as Dave Rubin
is he's not even close Joe Rogan has by
far the most successful podcast in the
world
hundreds of millions of views and
downloads uh per month
Etc it's at the cultural influence all
of that stuff they did it not because he
was white like they were like you know
we've got 100 Mil sitting around could
we find a white guy to help out they did
it because he is good he is creating
something of value but what she thinks
in her mind and again this is what
equity and modern leftism and wokism
does to everybody they see everything
through a racial lens so it's like if
let's just say Joe Rogan happened to be
black Joe Rogan happened to be black and
he was making 100 Mil do you think an
Asian podcaster would be out there being
like if Spotify doesn't give me I don't
know what accent that was but if a
Spotify doesn't give me 100 million too
then they're anti-asian it is all crazy
but again that that concept that Thomas
Soul was telling you this woman by the
way she's worth a ton of money I
actually saw her once in the LA airport
she was with Michael Jordan not Michael
Jordan the basketball player Michael
Jordan the actor you know uh Creed and
she was wearing these shoes these fluffy
shoes that clearly were like
multi-thousand dollar shoes this is not
a poor woman but she needs the
victimhood sunny hosting needs the
victimhood this is what Thomas Saul said
there are people who want to keep this
thing alive speaking of that we are now
going to show you a clip from the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC there's this guy Ellie mistal on
there major major race huckster uh with
a heck of a heck of a hairdo and here he
is telling everyone the Chief Justice of
the Supreme Court John Roberts is a
racist and has always been a racist
well all the media people especially all
the generally in kind of mainstream
media people especially who tend to act
like Roberts as some kind of moderate
good guy influence on the Supreme Court
make no mistake John Roberts has been an
enemy of black people voting for his
entire legal career indeed his first job
after he finished clerking was to work
for the Reagan White House arguing
against an expansion to the Voting
Rights Act that was initial that was
eventually pulled pushed through
um that was conceived of by uh the late
Lonnie granier that was so popular that
even Ronald Reagan had to sign that
expansion of the Voting Rights Act um
the Voting Rights Act was you uh was
confirmed under George W bush by a Voice
vote these are Bedrock American
principles that even Republicans agree
with but not John Roberts John Roberts
has been our enemy on voting rights for
his entire life and he's going to
continue to be our enemy this month
first off ladies and gentlemen I have to
do it it happens now and again an on the
Fly correction that was not the
televised mental institution of MSNBC
that was a program called Roland Roland
Martin unfiltered so there you go I've
corrected myself in real time everyone
can calm down uh basically everything he
said there was nonsense put it put aside
all the specifics like let's just put
aside the specific for a second you
really have to think about this do you
think that the Supreme that the head of
the Supreme Court right the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court do you
think he doesn't want black people to
vote do you think that there is anyone
anyone
that again is anywhere within anything
you could call roughly mainstream and I
would have a very wide Lane on that that
does not want people to vote because of
the color of their skin and is actively
working to stop a certain skin color uh
of people to vote it's it's completely
crazy but again that Thomas Soul quote
there's a set of people that need they
need their base to keep believing that
why so they will keep voting for the
Democrat grift that is the answer it it
ain't that difficult once you see it but
it's not just race now it's been race
right for for probably a decade it was
it was almost all based in you're a
racist you're a racist you're a racist
but then of course as you guys know
what's happened over the last couple
years the new thing is well for a while
it was you're a homophobe uh and then it
suddenly became you're a transphobe
right and this is a crazy notion you are
allowed to have personal beliefs uh you
are allowed to have religious beliefs
all of those things uh you may remember
this one this this is really something
else uh Dylan Mulvaney and you know know
Dylan Mulvaney Dylan is the guy who is a
girl who uh got his and or her face on
Bud Light causing Bud Light to lose
about 10 billion dollars in market share
uh Dylan a couple months ago was invited
Joe Biden uh well Joe Biden doesn't do
anything somebody behind Joe Biden
invited a whole bunch of tick-tockers
now Tick Tock is a Chinese spy app on a
lot of people's phones but they decided
to let everybody into the White House
because they were on Tick Tock so Joe
Biden invited Dylan Mulvaney to the
White House to for a Tick-Tock
conference and they started talking
about child Transitions and you might
remember this one you'll you'll see why
we're showing it to you
do you think States should have a right
to ban gender affirming health care I
don't think any state or anybody should
have the right to do that
as a moral question as a legal question
I just think it's wrong this is my 221st
day of publicly transitioning I love it
God love you all right first off by
every estimation Brock's not feeling
well today he's not here I'm not going
to have him Google it we there is every
reason to believe that that person still
has a wang so she's she or he is
counting the days and still has a wang
but okay uh first off uh it's not gender
affirming right we have to stop using
their language it's the least affirming
thing you could do when you chop
someone's genitals off right if someone
walked in here and chopped my genitals
off I wouldn't be like thank you for
affirming me okay I'm a eunuch and I'm
affirmed here we go that's one thing
also this this thing where Joe Biden and
I get it he doesn't know what he's
saying it's just like a muddled mess of
dribble but when he says it's a moral
and legal issue here it's moral well
first off well we can all first off my
morals have virtually nothing to do with
Joe Biden's morals I don't know that Joe
Biden knows his morals also so as far as
legal a hundred percent it's a legal
issue it's a state's issue states are
deciding it right now so you could take
that up to the Supreme Court if you want
Joe Biden but uh your morals thankfully
don't dictate the entire United States
and also thankfully we have something
called federalism but the reason I'm
showing you that clip from a few months
back uh is because Nikki Haley a couple
days ago did a CNN Town Hall where she
was asked about kids transitioning and
trans bathrooms and all of these things
and she had a fairly straightforward
answer she doesn't want kids to be
transitioned she doesn't think that the
gays are being attacked in any way that
makes you know and through any legal
means or anything like that it was it
was really just clean and clear and
fairly obvious to anyone saying but here
is White House Press Secretary Karin
jean-pierre's response to Nikki saying
that you shouldn't have Boys in girls
bathrooms
former Governor Nikki Haley suggested
that allowing transgender girls into
female locker rooms is driving up
Suicidal Thoughts I'm
girls wondering if you have any comments
so look I'm not going to go beyond what
we've talked about when it comes to
Department of Education when it comes to
this President as it relates to that
particular issue but look I think more
broadly what we have seen from
Republicans just across the country as
it relates to transgender youth as it
relates to the lgbtqi plus Community
we've seen more than 600 bills many of
those are are targeted at transgender
Youth and and that is something that the
president's going to continue to speak
out against it is appalling what we're
seeing the hate the attack on this
community and so the president's going
to be very clear that he supports the
lgbtq plus Community this is pride month
as you know he's going to continue to
lift up the community and all their
accomplishments celebrate them and so
I'll just I'll just leave it there for
now you got to admire the way they do it
right why do what do I always say about
the work it's a parasite in the system
and it often overtakes the system so you
have to admire that it's doing what it's
set out to do right like alien in the
first alien movie the doctor on board
the ship as it's killing everybody
admires it because it's actually
accomplishing what its goals are when
she talks about the hate literally Nikki
Haley is up there like let's not have
Boys in girls bathrooms because it's
upsetting the girls and now girls are
having all sorts of issues which we know
girls are having all sorts of issues
suicide and depression and all these
things boys have another version of it
but all Nikki is saying is what we all
knew to be true 10 years ago you don't
have boys and girls bathrooms very
simple not controversial no one in their
right mind thought that was
controversial 10 years ago now the
mainstream position and the position of
this Administration is that a 15 year
old boy just announces the next day
right my name was Adam you all knew me
as Adam now my name's Anna and I put on
a dress I'm going into that girl girls
bathroom and I'm going to watch all
those girls change and oh I've got a
wang and they're going to have to look
at that and blah blah blah blah blah and
if you push back against that what does
this Administration call you they call
you a hater and a bigot and all of those
things it is patently patently absurd
but if you want to see some real
absurdity this is a fine segue to
absurdity there is a guy uh up in the
San Francisco area he is California
state legislator Scott weiner yes his
name is Weiner and he's big on chopping
off wieners uh you can't make this stuff
up here he is honoring the drag queens
from really what is an anti-catholic
hate group at the Capitol just look at
this
so proud of uh sister Roma and her work
in the community and I'm proud of
California for standing strong
to support lgbtq people as our community
is under assault in the rest of the
country
sister Romo went on to say it's an
incredible honor to have been nominated
she says being recognized not only means
a lot to her but the lgbtq community at
large okay first off I don't know what
they mean by her is that person a woman
or a man or what
um The Sisters of the of Perpetual
Indulgence is what they go she's not a
she's not a real sister in any way this
is not a legitimate sort of religious
group or anything like that again nobody
the G's have just nothing to do with
this it's so boring and and ridiculous
but but it's interesting they never when
they when they're going after you know
when they're mock the whole purpose of
this group really is to is to mock
Christians right it's to mock Catholics
in essence right like they're pretending
that they're like this order of nuns
it's funny that they never do this with
Muslims right isn't that bizarre they
never dress up like a bunch of Muslims
in Drag and see how that goes right and
then the LA Dodgers are honoring this
group literally honoring this group we
covered that last week it's funny I I
wonder if they would do that why doesn't
Scott weiner have the balls you see what
I did there to do that you guys get
exactly what's going on these people by
the grace of God they live in a largely
Christian Society because only
Christians would put up with this
sanity so what is the point of showing
you that the left is keeping racism and
this
neo-gender lunacy on life support the
point is that this is not your father's
Democrat Party anymore check out uh this
tweet from the end wokman's Twitter
account which I like of course what
you're seeing there is JFK uh with his
child I assume that's uh is that our
well that would be uh JFK Jr maybe or
maybe it was the was there was the
daughter too they had a daughter I'm
actually blanking did JFK have a
daughter I actually can't remember uh
but maybe it's JFK Jr uh and uh here's
the Democrat Party of today there you go
it's a little heavy-handed but you get
it but why does this keep happening why
does this endless slog and slide into
nothingness keep happening there are a
couple decent Democrats out there you
guys know that for all my differences
with Bill Maher I haven't shown a clip
of him in quite some time I've been
trying to kind of show them the light a
little bit maybe he'll never quite get
there but even if he doesn't he is I
think roughly especially on the Free
Speech stuff a sane Democrat uh I want
to watch I want to show you this clip
this is Bill Maher on Jimmy Kimmel who
is not a same Democrat in September of
2021 talking about how the Democrats and
the mainstream media basically
cause their base not to believe in truth
in this case he's talking about covid
but I think you can see how that then
gets extrapolated through the race thing
the gender thing and the rest of it take
a look
but I have to cite a survey that was in
the New York Times which is a liberal
paper so they weren't looking for this
answer but they were talking about uh
this the question was what do you think
the chances are that you would have to
go to the hospital if you got coveted
and Democrats thought that was way
higher than Republicans 41 percent of
democrat and the answer is between one
and five percent okay
41 percent of Democrats thought it was
over 50 percent
another 28 thought it was 20 to 49 so 70
percent of Democrats thought it was way
way higher than it really was
liberal media has to take a little
responsibility for that for scaring the
out of people
and the reason why I'm bringing this up
is because it's much harder for every
touring act to sell tickets in blue
States oh interesting they were afraid
to go out of the house I see whereas in
red States it's all good to go uh-huh so
I just want to say to those people in
San Rafael in Pittsburgh and New York I
ain't going to give it to you I promise
I you know it's safe we we're doing
everything we can there's distancing
there's masking uh and enjoy live life
you did get it embraced life you did get
it
I got an after I was vaccinated
so you got to give Bill more credit
there right like he's going into a far
Lefty talk show host show now they're
friends actually we discussed it when I
was on the club random podcast their
friends obviously you know my feelings
about uh blackface Jimmy Kimmel
um but the audience there you could feel
how quiet they are and how afraid of
laughing there because he's calling out
their machine it is the Democrat machine
that made Democrats go covid crazy it is
the Democrat and media machine right it
is the cable news networks it's big Tech
all that that monstrous machine we're
always talking about that has caused a
certain set of people that used to be
sane moderates to all go bananas so they
can't differentiate between boys and
girls anymore they can't accept that we
are not a systemically racist Nation etc
etc so good for Bill Maher for trying to
call that out but let's uh continue
because there is another sane Democrat
and I think he's about to find out what
happens when you're a sane Democrat and
it ain't pretty Democratic presidential
candidate RFK oh let me back up for one
second that was Caroline Kennedy in the
picture thank you I knew there was a
daughter there it was Mike and honor
named Caroline candy was uh with uh with
President uh Kennedy there
um JF RFK Jr there's a lot of FKS here
uh RFK Jr Robert F Kennedy Jr is running
for president on the Democrat side he's
polling at about 20 percent that is
quite substantial but the Democrats are
making it clear they are not putting
Biden on a debate stage they are just
going to ignore this guy it's a little
unclear to me exactly why he's a
Democrat still I think it has mostly to
do with environment stuff I'm going to
ask him about it uh soon enough uh in
any event he went on Jordan Peterson's
podcast and uh wait this is from
Jordan's show right no this sorry this
one
oh sorry this one's on Fox we're gonna
do that one first uh he went on Fox uh
and he was talking about uh calling out
both Trump and Biden when it came to the
lockdowns and then what happened to the
country economically after that
I'd like either uh President Biden or
president Trump
explain the lockdowns to us that was a
16 trillion dollar mistake we shifted
four trillion dollars in wealth from the
middle class in this country to the
super Ridge this new aristocracy of
billionaires
the lockdown has created a billionaire a
day 500 new billionaires and the people
who came into the lockdown with a
billion dollars
increased their wealth by 30 percent we
had you know 41 percent of black owned
businesses will never reopen some of
those businesses had two or three
generations of Sweat Equity of currency
and um we closed 3.3 million businesses
without due process without judge
compensation the White House both white
houses were collaborating with Amazon
and with the other social media sites to
shut down their competitors Amazon got
to shut down 3.3 million competitors and
we got it two-year Less in the entire
public and out of you know do our
shopping on Amazon and those businesses
those retail businesses which are the
heart and soul
of the middle class and our democracy
are now shut down
isn't that refreshing like seeing an
actual Democrat who I may have some dis
disagreements with which would be
absolutely just fine and it would be
great to talk about them truly but a
Democrat not talking down to his
constituents right he's saying Biden
screwed up he's saying Trump screwed up
but he's saying hard truths that it's
the Democrats really who are the ones
that have to think about the covid stuff
more than Republicans like just listen
to Bill Maher what's Bill Maher saying
Hey I want to go out on the road and
tour of course he's saying this you know
this is a year and a half ago or so but
it still to some extent happening right
now uh I want to go out on the road and
tour and people aren't showing up in
blue States right we can't tour in blue
States because people won't come and
that's really what RFK is saying right
there like the the Democrat machine has
scared people to the point that again
they believe in all of these crazy
things you know I think it's worth
mentioning because it's come up a few
times and I see comments about it uh
that RFK actually has a condition it's a
medical condition called called
spasmodic dysfunction and that's why his
voice has that sort of there's some
gravel in his voice and it's a little uh
inconsistent or something I know a lot
of people have asked about that I don't
know much more about the condition
itself but I think it is worth
mentioning uh anyway uh you know Elon
Musk after
he had Ron DeSantis about a week and a
half ago launched the campaign on
Twitter spaces Elon Musk made it very
clear that every single presidential
candidate is welcome to do the exact
same thing I sincerely doubt that Joe
Biden is going to do it I suspect that a
couple of the Republicans will kind of
be afraid to do it too if you're going
to stick more to talking points but RFK
Jr did go on there yesterday with Elon
and listen to the way again talk about
not talking down and pandering to your
base but actually telling them some hard
truths that the truths that then come
with sane policy listen to this
over the next three days be meeting with
people from the border patrol and
elsewhere to try to formulate policies
that will seal the Border permanently in
stressing the school systems the
stressing the social services for people
who are already for Americans who are
already struggling with it needs to be
turned off
so that was RFK saying that if he were
president he would seal off the southern
isn't that really something like think
about that that is a guy who's running
to be president as a Democrat Democrats
by and large in essence want open
borders they don't come out and say it
but what they basic We have basically
had an open border and what they
basically want is once people are here
they cannot be kicked out they are going
to get phones they are going to get
services or as we've shown you over the
last couple weeks and they're virtually
only covering on Fox at a mainstream
level they are literally people get here
illegally then you get your you know
these temporary immigration papers that
tell you when you'll be uh you know when
you'll get your chance in court and
they're kicking them off to three years
so you're allowed to stay in the country
for three years until you get your court
case if that court case ever arrives so
here he is saying something that's very
trumpy isn't it very trumpy like we are
gonna seal the freaking border now that
I suppose the base is not going to like
that but isn't it refreshing again for
your friends that or or for you watching
this if you're a moderate Democrat isn't
that basically what you have been
waiting for I think so but the question
again is why does all of this keep
happening why does the race stuff keep
happening why does the gender stuff keep
happening why does the open border stuff
keep happening well there actually is a
reason for it uh this video has been
making the rounds it's from 2017 and it
is the CEO of BlackRock Larry Fink along
with the CEO of Amex American Express
explaining how they basically use their
conglomerates to quote Force behaviors
on people this is wild and remember this
is about six seven years ago so think
about what we've been through for the
last six seven years now listen to this
you you now make a point of that's
that's an investment criteria for you
well behaviors are going to have to
change and this is one thing we're going
to we're asking companies
you have to force behaviors and at
BlackRock we are forcing behaviors uh 54
of the incoming class are women we we
added four more points in terms of
diverse uh employment this year and it
will if it's you know what we're doing
internally is if you don't achieve these
levels of impact your compensation could
be impacted okay we're doing the same
thing and so it's just it you have to
force behaviors and if you don't force
behaviors whether it's gender or race or
just any way you want to say the
composition of your team
you're going to be impacted and that's
not just not recruiting it is
development as Ken said and ultimately
it's still going to take time but I am
just as much shocked as Ken is that we
have not
seen more opportunities and we're going
to have to force change how do you get
it guys Force change Force behaviors
Larry Fink by the way has been the CEO
of BlackRock I think since 1988 he is
still the CEO of BlackRock he is a white
man I looks like in in maybe his early
to mid 60s has not stepped down for a
black lesbian yet it's very very bizarre
I thought change starts with you the man
in the mirror what are you doing dude
but now do you get it so these companies
that then push these crazy policies on
all of their subsidiaries are actually
injecting racism injecting gender
discrimination against say straight
people etc etc into all these things so
there's a clean path right that's what
I'm trying to lay out to you guys today
when every day we wake up and there's
more craziness or why does the craziness
never stop there's a there's a clear
reason for it but I think that there's
some chances out of this obviously and
I've done now 45 minutes of a show
without mentioning Rhonda santis
obviously he's the the Republican and
then I would say the wide American
answer to this because he's done it so
well here but the Democrats have a
glimmer of hope it's not going to work
but it's worthy of talking about it's
worthy of helping people wake up the
positive Vision that RFK Jr is talking
about again whether I have some
disagreements with him probably on on
environmental stuff mostly like where
that should come from private or public
or whatever
but there needs to be a positive Vision
going forward for America so now we can
get to the clip of RFK Jr I think this
was just dropped this morning on
Jordan's podcast uh talking about sort
of his his philosophy and something that
a certain famous relative of his once
said
you're willing to avoid or would like to
avoid using
using fear as a motivating factor when
you're making your case for
environmental concerns okay well that
you know that seems to be a good answer
on the motivational front the reason
that FDR
said the only thing that we have to fear
is fear itself and he said that you know
it wasn't during World War II it was in
1932 and he said that because the
Depression had uh landed you know in the
United States and Europe and he he's all
we we had you know we had left wing
uh leaders Democrats like Huey Long that
a third of the country wanted to turn
you know essentially socialists or
communists
we had a right wing uh like like Father
Charles Coughlin who wanted to bring the
the the uh Nation fascists the people
that lost faith in democracy
it was a one out of every four Americans
was unemployed 2200 Banks had closed you
know it was crashing and everybody was
convinced by that democracy and
capitalism had failed
you had to look for a new system we
would we can write this we can change it
we can recover what we had but we just
have to stay out of fear because that is
the weapon of tyrants guys I think this
is a Reuben report first I have to issue
a second correction obviously RFK Jr is
not related to FDR the quote of course
is the only thing we have to fear is
fear itself so how do we tie everything
that we're talking about together here
well keeping racism alive
pushing the idea that if you don't want
boys and girls bathrooms that somehow
you're a hater that right that you hate
that person as opposed to protecting
girls or whatever it might be these are
all things that are based in fear you
are trying to make it seem like like
there is evil everywhere and only if you
give more power to the government and or
these corporations that that somehow
that will alleviate that fear I would
like to read that Thomas Soul quote one
more time
racism is not dead but it is on life
support kept Alive by politicians race
Hustlers and people who get a sense of
superiority by denouncing others as
racist so the point is if a certain set
of people keep racism alive and it is
alive in that it's on life support and
they are constantly injecting it with
steroids to keep it moving
then the rest of us just have to move on
they will not stop Sunny Hosten will not
have the come to Jesus moment right
these people will not stop but the rest
of us actually especially because of new
technology and everything else will have
a chance to basically separate from them
and think of the world in a new way and
build new things so the solution the
positive path forward
is to only fear nothing but fear itself
um and you know what there was another
guy that actually is and was related to
RFK now I'll get it right name JFK and
you might remember what he once said
and so
so what you can do for your country
RFK JFK
FDR I'm djr this has been the Reuben
report join us for a post game show
right now at
reubenreport.locals.com and we will see
everybody tomorrow
Donald Trump says he makes fun of people
he belittles people he lies I don't do
any of those things can't take away her
gum you're full of all right damn
liar man your lying dog face pony
soldier clap for that you stupid boxers
ar-14 okay this is not okay hold on hold
on all right
wow there's a lot of guys no I wish we
were in high school I could take him
behind the gym let's do push-ups
together what's the crime let's do
whatever you want to do what do you
think huh
are you a joke what do you say
look here's the deal
you're getting nervous man but Biden
quickly became agitated when Fallon
didn't agree to support him in the
caucuses we got to stop building and
replacing Pipelines
I did not expect to be told to leave to
go vote for somebody else and then to be
lectured about and then he presses on
Fallon's chest pokes him with a finger
and finally grabs his jacket with two
hands it was not appropriate interaction
for anybody I mean if I'd done that to
him the security would have been all
over me
slush
[Music]